if they're the right medicine for you
they can actually help balance your
brain
if they're the wrong medicine
and this is where i learned to stop
prescribing benzos
uh
they can hurt you
and let me just be clear i'm not opposed
to psychiatric
medications some people need them
i'm opposed to that's the first and only
thing you do
because many of them
change your brain to need them
in order for you to feel normal
[Music]
welcome to the michaela peterson podcast
episode 112. dr daniel ayman is one of
america's leading psychiatrists and
brain health experts he's authored or
co-authored over 80 professional
articles and more than 40 books
including new york times mega best
seller change your brain change your
life
and his newest one your brain is always
listening he's appeared on dr phil larry
king dr oz the doctors in the view he's
treated justin bieber miley cyrus
he studies brain scans and how to heal
brains super cutting edge stuff
i'm going to go get my brain scanned in
november to see what's wrong with me
hopefully nothing too obvious
we spoke about spect scans the type of
scan he does testing neurotransmitter
levels what causes a toxic brain why
psychiatry is failing the worst things
you can do for your brain hyperbaric
oxygen supplements to increase serotonin
a good diet for your brain and more
please hit subscribe if you enjoy this
content this episode was also filmed
when my dad was not doing very well and
he's doing much better so take that into
consideration while watching it and
don't be too worried about us please
enjoy this episode
[Music]
dr daniel ayman welcome to my podcast
thanks so much for having me
so
i brought you on because of your work on
brains and
the problems i've had with my brain
and my dad has had with his brain and i
thought i could take this time to learn
a whole bunch of things from you so
that's the goal but before we get
started this is your book i have it here
uh could you give a brief background
about who you are and what it is you do
well
again thank you for having me i'm a
psychiatrist by training
but i learned early on that
psychiatrists are the only medical
doctors who never look at the organ they
treat and so for the last 30 years i've
been looking at brains we do a study at
amen clinics called brain spect imaging
specs
looks at blood flow and activity
looks at how the brain works and we
built this database of about 186 000
scans
on people from 150 countries and it just
informs every aspect
of my life
um and it's been quite the wild ride to
do something your colleagues don't do
so
that's been fun uh but i'm also a dad
and a grandfather and a husband
and an author and i love teaching people
about the cool things the brain has
taught me
okay so
before we delve very deep into that
what exactly is a spect scan
spec stands for
single photon emission computed
tomography it's a nuclear medicine study
that looks at blood flow and
it looks at how your brain
works and it basically shows us three
things
is it healthy
under active
or over active
it lets me
tell the health of your brain
gives me a sense of how old your brain
is are you a girl or are you a boy
because girls have wildly different
brains
than boys do and
and it teaches you to actually fall in
love with your brain
because you want it to be better
so do you basically bring somebody in
scan their brain and then compare their
brain to the average brain
well if you came to see me
we would take
a really good history because we'd want
to know the story of your life
and then we would scan you twice once it
rests and once when you do a
concentration
task
and
we
know what a healthy brain
looks like right when you've seen as
many as we've seen uh we also did a
large study on healthy
which is actually rare
i just tell people make a list of 10 of
your friends and half of them
need to see me
or are medicating themselves
so
um
we we have a really good idea what a
healthy brain
looks like
and then that informs both the diagnosis
what we think is the problem
and then how we target help
for it
okay
have you seen
okay
this is just way out in left field but
have you seen any evidence of psych meds
causing brain changes
yes
okay
okay
so
if they're the right medicine for you
they can actually help balance your
brain
if they're the wrong medicine
and this is where i learned to stop
prescribing benzos
uh
they can hurt you
um
and many of the psych meds
and let me just be clear i'm not opposed
to psychiatric
medications some people need them
i'm opposed to that's the first and only
thing you do
because many of them
change your brain
to need them
in order for you to feel normal and i'm
not okay with that i want to teach my
patients skills
and not just give them pills
and i want you to love your brain
because when your brain works right your
mind works right people often miss that
central point
your brain creates your mind and so if
your brain is not healthy
your mind is not going to be as healthy
as it could be
okay
okay so you think brain impacts mind and
not the other way around
well
if you're an undisciplined thinker
that'll have a negative impact on how
your brain actually works
but i often think of it like hardware
and software you've got to get the
hardware right first
and then work on programming it and too
often
[Music]
in my new book your brain is always
listening i actually have a brand new
12-step program because the 12-step
program was developed 85 years ago and
there's no neuroscience with it
and i'm like step three for me is get
your brain right
and
then it's just so much easier to get
control over the addictions in your life
okay so you had an
um i'm a fairly
i said this recently on podcast i'm
really open but i'm also fairly
skeptical and your stuff is so
interesting
i find it and i i believe i mean i
believe in what you're doing but there i
have some questions and some of the
questions are you'll you'll do a scan on
say somebody
who
drinks a lot
and then say you know the brain looks
different from the average brain
they drink a lot and that's impacting
their behavior
is it possible that the behavior is what
changed the brain like that and not the
drinking or is that just not likely at
all
well i mean you can act
for all sorts of reasons the reason i've
not been a fan of alcohol
is it makes your brain look older
than you are
and
all the problems i've seen as a
psychiatrist for the last 40 years
alcohol just tends to make worse you're
more likely to make bad decisions you're
more likely to beat your spouse you're
more likely to drive when you shouldn't
be driving i mean
you know ultimately our success
is a sum
of all the decisions
that we make
and i just don't want things polluting
your
decisions
that you make
and i wrote a blog last year it was our
number one blog of the whole year and it
was called i told you so
and so i've not been a fan ever since i
started ordering scans and i saw they
looked older
than you were um and last year the
american cancer society came out against
any alcohol i mean for a big prestigious
body like that to say you shouldn't
drink because it increased the risk of
seven different
types of cancer
and i start the blog with when i dated
my wife she told me she would never tell
me i told you so
and she lied it's like her favorite
thing to say
and so
and then i go but i did tell you
that alcohol is not a health food
yeah okay
is there any
is there anything you can do
infrequently that you can get away with
like what if this is once in a blue moon
and that goes for not just alcohol but
any
drug people would be using like are
one-off times okay
sometimes or is that just you know is it
never okay and people are just
not telling you about it
well you know i can't say you can never
have a drink because that's probably not
rational
but
the more
you do it the worse it gets and
ultimately
it's about love
like we just finished a 30-day happiness
challenge
and
one of it's based on these seven big
ideas and one of them is only love food
that loves you back it's
a relationship
with food and i don't know if you've
ever been in a bad relationship but i've
been in a bad relationship and i'm not
doing it anymore i'm just not and i'm
for certain not doing it with food or
with alcohol or with other
things does it mean i never have an ice
cream cone um well mostly only if i go
to italy but
it's i just want to do the right thing
because it's about love
and i
have brain envy i often say freud was
wrong penis envy's not the cause of
anybody's problem i've not seen it once
in 40 years it's brain envy we need to
like get focused on love the three
pounds of fat between your ears and
you're going to love your life a whole
bunch more oh yeah
okay so i've got some random questions
to throw at you is it possible to test
neurotransmitter levels because i know
when people are told they're depressed
sometimes they say oh you're you have a
deficiency in serotonin or there's
something wrong with your brain you're
not getting enough of it can you
actually test if somebody's low in gaba
or serotonin or any of the
neurotransmitters you know not with
urine that you know there's a lot of
people that do urine or
testing it just doesn't seem to relate
to what's going on in your brain because
you have this thing called the blood
brain barrier and what's in your blood
is not
highly correlated to what's in your
brain i mean yes you can do a spinal tap
and directly measure but that's a little
bit invasive yeah you know i often think
if you have add likely you have low
dopamine if you have ocd
or you have the worried kind of
depression your serotonin could use a
jump start if you're anxious raising
gaba does seem to help
i'd prefer to do it in natural ways at
least to start see if i could get away
with that
um
but yeah there's some truth to
neurotransmitter abnormalities
can cause us to feel funky uh
but not easy to measure in your blood or
your urine
okay so when somebody well take i mean
people are all aware of my dad he was on
antidepressants then he was on
benzodiazepines
and then they just like ruined his life
um and what you're told when somebody's
on
benzos or ssris is that when you take
them away so if you end up having a
dependency on them you take them away
and then your body has a problem with
say gaba
how do how do any scientists know that
that's the case
so they really infer it so from the
scans
what we see is low
gaba
goes with excessive activity in the
limbic or emotional
parts of the brain
and so giving things that raise gaba
gabapentin would be one tends to sort of
calm that down
magnesium tends to calm it down and so
in this country we pass out benzos like
candy
and it's just insane
that someone can go to the emergency
room for a panic attack
and end up with gap end up with xanax
and no one ever taught him diaphragmatic
breathing and it's like really
no one ever taught them simple hypnotic
or meditation uh techniques they're
giving them a drug that changes their
brain
and they can become dependent on it and
that's
insane
i mean it's really insane because all of
us in medical school learn the first
year
first do no harm
from from what i've learned from the
doctors i've spoken with um especially
ones that are like main purely
mainstream is that
most doctors aren't aware that these
kind of medications actually cause brain
changes
like they didn't know that they assumed
that well i don't think a lot of them
know that they're dependents forming
especially something like an ssri but i
didn't realize that you could do scans
that could show brain do you have brain
changes before and after medication
i do
and i have positive changes for people
who are on the right stuff
and negative changes for people who are
on the wrong stuff
and so
when i met tana when i met my wife
and i looked at her skin because if i'm
dating you and i really like you i'm
looking at your brain it's the most
important part of you i want to see
and
um
and she told me when she had thyroid
cancer in her 20s that she got depressed
and i looked at her and i said i hope
they didn't put you on prozac
and she goes why why do you say that
because they put me on prozac and it
dis-inhibited me she did things yeah
there's no way she would have done
uh
without it
and she has sleepy frontal lobes so the
front part of her brain is low in blood
flow what prozac does
is it lowers it further
and so for the right person who starts
with a busy
frontal lobe you know they're worried
and rigid and inflexible and if things
don't go their way they get upset well
prozac tends to calm that down
and they feel better
but if you start with sleepy frontal
lobes it comes that down which basically
takes the break off of your behavior and
you end up doing
or saying things you wouldn't normally
do or
say
and
she has a new book out called the
relentless courage of a scared child and
there's a whole chapter on how prozac
made her a different person
that's wild okay
uh
my my background i've got a weird health
history but i was on sip relax a
ridiculous amount of ciprolex for almost
12 years and i had the same
um disinhibition you'd say for sure um
it did seem to help but like it totally
messed me up and i haven't been on it
for about five years getting off of it
almost wrecked me
like i had two and a half years of just
like i had some visual hallucinations it
was absurd
uh and i'm fine now i fix things with
diet but
ciprolex
was crazy i remember trusting trying an
snri and i only took it for two days
because i was absurdly angry
i had wellbutrin i ended up having a
seizure it was really interesting to
hear about
after going through some of these things
it's your brain i assume
no i had well i've had
after i had a seizure that's not true
after i had a seizure i had to scan but
they're like no everything's normal but
it was what a cat scan probably right so
which is an anatomical scan
which are very rarely
useful in psychiatry
but
what i'm trying to do see i hate the
words
mental illness hate those because they
shame people they stigmatize people call
someone mental that's not a good thing
and they're wrong
because these are brain health issues
that steal people's minds
and that idea
everybody wants a better brain
nobody wants a mental illness
and
you know with a lot of celebrities
coming out i have a mental illness yeah
i'm like that's not going to be helpful
what's going to be helpful
is i want a better brain and when i got
a better brain
my mood was better my focus was better i
was less
anxious so i wrote another book called
the end of mental illness because we
need to have a different discussion
about this uh we want people to develop
brain envy and the habits that get them
a better brain because that's how you
treat depression that's how you treat
anxiety disorders the new fads of
ayahuasca and magic mushrooms and
i'm just like come on we can do better
than this
i like magic mushrooms
but it wasn't what transformed my health
what transformed my health i think was
diet and
mindset and getting off of medication
that's what like changed changed my
life
this episode is brought to you by
grass-fed beef organs
by ancestral supplements ancestral
supplements makes new zealand-sourced
nose-to-tail organ meats bone marrow and
beef organs in simple convenient gelatin
capsules traditional peoples native
americans and early ancestral healers
believed that eating the organs from a
healthy animal would strengthen and
support the health of the corresponding
organ of the individual for instance the
traditional way of treating a person
with a weak heart was to feed the person
the heart of a healthy animal similarly
eating the kidneys of a healthy animal
was believed to support urinary ailments
and overall kidney health pancreas was
fed to people with digestive problems
and spleen was fed to people with immune
and blood deficiencies
our early ancestors knew this which is
why their traditional diets included the
frequent and nourishing consumption of
nose-to-tail organs visit
ancestralsupplements.com
see what they can do for you
ancestral supplements putting back in
what the modern world has left out i
hope you enjoy the rest of this episode
okay what do you do so you must deal
with a lot of people who have
dependencies and addictions and brain
injuries and that's why they're coming
to you what like what's the kind of
person that comes to see you
um people who
want a better brain they've read one of
my books or seen me on television
people who failed so on average our
patients
have failed 3.3 providers and six
medications and they just they want a
different
approach
and we do a formal outcome study on
everybody we see
um because that's our core value is
outcomes we want people to get well
yeah 85
of people come to see us at six months
or better and we're really happy about
that not everybody and we clearly don't
know everything
but if you don't look
you don't know
that
the traumatic brain injury may have
changed your life stephen
uh as an example he's a musician and he
gives me permission to share this he and
i did
a
facebook video that got like 8 million
views stephen hilton
and he's depressed his whole life and
found methamphetamines and he said that
turned his brain on when he was 16 and
then he found alcohol
but
even when he went to treatment and got
rid of those he had struggled with
depression his whole life when i saw his
brain damaged to the right front damaged
to the right temporal lobe now he'd seen
like a dozen psychiatrists psychologists
therapists
and no one had ever asked him so when
did you have a brain injury
because you can see it on the skin
and he said no one's asked me that
before he said i was three years old and
i fell down a flight of stairs i went to
the hospital
and
he said do you think that fall could
have caused a lifetime of depression
unlike absolutely could have
undiagnosed brain injuries are a major
cause of
homelessness addiction depression panic
attacks suicide adhd
put him in a hyperbaric chamber put him
on some supplements
taught him not to believe every stupid
thing he thinks his brain is better he's
better which means his marriage is
better which means his ability to be a
parent is better
and if you don't know
you're flying blind
and why is that okay i just don't
understand
why that would would be okay i mean why
do we treat
the brain with less
reverence than we treat the heart right
you have chest pain they're looking at
your heart in five different ways
okay
definitely
should you have a ridiculous waiting
list
[Music]
oh wow around the country and we're just
crazy busy
but
you know there's 40 of us or
psychiatrists and we love what we do
and where are you you guys where um i'm
i'm in canada not forever but in canada
yeah
so i think i mean i feel most people
aren't aware like i wasn't aware you
could go somewhere and get scans that
showed brain activity i've seen that in
documentaries i didn't realize that was
something you could do other than you
know an mri or a cat scan
yeah no we did in fact the canadian
association of nuclear medicine
uh i so i've been at war with my
colleagues for 30 years uh because
they've been telling me i'm crazy and i
can't see what i see and
um i've been called every bad name you
can think of
but
when you see you cannot unsee
and so to go back to making diagnoses
based on symptom clusters with no
biological data no i can't do that
that's just ridiculous
recently in may actually the canadian
association of nuclear medicine wrote
new procedure guidelines for brain spect
imaging
basically as if i wrote them
and they said it's time
to use this
and i'm thrilled
about that it was like one of the
happiest moments of my life when you
know i had a group of a professional
scientific body go come on let's start
looking because if you don't look you
don't know
okay so when someone comes in
you show them their brain and you show
them how it lights up differently than
the average brain because you've scanned
hundreds and thousands of them
that's correct right
and then you change their
like
you talked a little bit about how you
told him not to believe everything he
thought
which i think is really important so how
does that end up changing your brain
or does that end up changing your brain
or so when you come into that
so if you came to see me
history look at your brain
and then develop a plan and i always
think of people in four big circles it's
like what's the biology
what's the physical functioning of your
brain and body got to get those right
what's this psychology how are you
thinking what's your development like
what's this social circle how are you
getting along with the people you care
about
and the spiritual circle which is why
the heck do you care what is your
deepest sense of meaning and purpose so
biology
change your
diet
gonna probably supplement your brain
if you're schizophrenic or brittle
bipolar i'm probably going to add
medication in as well
psychologically i'm going to teach you
to kill the ants the automatic negative
thoughts the thoughts that come into
your mind automatically and ruin your
day
there's nowhere in school where they
teach us to manage our minds
and so
whenever you're sad or mad or nervous or
out of control i want you to write down
what you're thinking
and we're going to investigate it to see
is it helping you or is it hurting you i
was 28 years old and in my psychiatric
residency before i learned i didn't have
to believe every stupid thing i thought
and there's also a fun technique i give
my patients called give your mind a name
so gaining psychological distance from
the noise in your head it's actually
there's a great scene in the new disney
movie luca
where the main character you know his
friend teaches him to give his mind a
name and tell it to shut up it's really
fun and fascinating
but really working in those four circles
it's what i want you to be a whole
healthy
happy
person
and that doesn't come from taking this
or that medication
i think i was in grade five when i
decided that some of the thoughts i was
having didn't make any sense but i was
having some pretty wild thoughts
uh have you seen
brain scans on
uh people with akathesia
i have
um
so accuracy is there a pattern
low basal ganglia
activity so the basal ganglia is
involved in smooth motor movement
and it's not healthy
in people who have academia why do you
ask
so my dad from taking psych meds has
academia
we've been battling it for a number of
years you know and one of the things i
think
is when you have a neurological
condition whether it's akashesia or
aphasia or parkinson's disease or even
early alzheimer's disease
it's critical
to then put the brain in a healing
environment
and too often doctors never talk about
that they don't talk about your diet
they don't talk about things like
hyperbaric oxygen therapy
they're like here take this medicine or
that medicine
and that's it
and that's insane because the brain is
an organ like your heart is an organ
and
it's going to get better or worse
depending on what i do today
have you seen things like alzheimer's
and dementia and parkinson's improve
after looking at scans and changing diet
and adding supplements i have in fact i
wrote
preventing alzheimer's in 2004.
and i did a follow-up to it um recently
called memory rescue it's one of my most
popular books and
if you have
alzheimer's disease
need to look at the brain because
there's so many different roads
to alzheimer's disease it's not one
thing and you know
michaela if you said hey daniel what's
the single most important thing you've
learned from 186 000 scans
mild traumatic brain injury ruins
people's lives and nobody knows about it
the second thing i learned is all
psychiatric illnesses
all of them
are not single or simple disorders they
all have multiple types
so giving someone the diagnosis of
depression is like giving them the
diagnosis of fever or chest pain it's
ridiculous it's like it's like well
what's causing that it's not telling you
what's causing it or what to do for it
an alzheimer's is i have this great case
of this guy who's diagnosed by us
neurologists with alzheimer's disease
from seattle he came to see me and i
scanned him the pattern for alzheimer's
disease was described in 1989
um
bilateral parietal top back part of your
brain temporal lobe decreases classic
well he didn't have that what he had was
big ventricles
something called normal pressure
hydrocephalus
and
draining the extra fluid in his brain
gave him
but how would you know
unless you looked
and so
alzheimer's can be caused from
you have the genetic tendency to it and
you have too much buildup
of a sticky plaque called beta amyloid
because from head trauma from infections
like lyme and i know now because i have
hundreds of covered brains
covet is not good for your brain and for
some people it can damage their brain so
infections
toxins um i just recently doing a
program with firefighters uh almost all
of them have toxic brains because of the
toxic fumes
how do you test
what is sorry i i don't mean to
interrupt um what how do you what does a
toxic brain look like
so it looks like the alcoholic brain so
people go to my instagram and they can
see the shriveled bumpy
brain but
what if i see it and you're not a
drinker you're not a drug addict
oh my god i did dave asprey's brain the
founder of bulletproof and his brain
just looked terrible and it turned out
he was living in a mold-filled home so
mold
can do it
things like lyme disease can do it
anesthesia
can do it vulnerable
brains near drownings can do it it's
like if you don't love your brain
so many things can hurt it that people
just aren't aware of and i'm like a
psychiatrist why do i care whether or
not you live in a mold-filled home
because it'll make you depressed if i
don't fix that you know prozac isn't
fixing your mold-filled environment
i'm so horrified right now like partly
because
if you have a brain problem or a
neurological problem looking at a brain
seems like a really obvious option and i
didn't realize you could look at the
brain like that
how did how do people not know about
spect scans and why is that not
the first step in diagnosing a
neurological or psychiatric disorder
that's insane oh my god
wow you've been doing this for 30 years
you must be so frustrated not for lack
of trying on my work
but you know the reason it didn't sort
of take off when i got fascinated by it
is it directly
opposes the diagnostic system
so the diagnostic system is you tell the
doctor your symptoms
and he puts it together
in a diagnosis like when lincoln was
depressed in 1840 he went to his doctor
told him what was going on his doctor
said you're depressed
and then treated him
it's the same thing that happens in
2021
and when you look at it through my eyes
you go that's insane
because how do you know why they're
depressed is their brain working too
hard is it not working hard enough is it
hurt is it toxic
and if you don't know
you fly blind
and that's why
psychiatry is diminished and it's what
is their own damn fault
because they're not embracing what other
medical specialties do
which is imaging
what other medical specialists wouldn't
look
at the problem
not one
so what do you do for somebody who's
already brain damaged i mean most people
listening to this podcast are like [ __ ]
i fell down the i like i fell down the
stairs broke my head open when i was two
i was like was that the cause of all my
health problems maybe like i feel like
everybody has something who doesn't have
a concussion doesn't everyone have a
concussion
so i did a big nfl study when the nfl
was lying they had a problem
and
i've scanned and treated
300 nfl players
high levels of damage right that's not a
surprise nobody's surprised by that
anymore
80 of my players get better when i put
them on a rehabilitation program
so
if you see your brain
if you learn to love your brain
well you can make it better
i mean every day by your behavior you're
making it better
or you're making it worse
and if we can see it
then we just get serious about okay
let's do these things i'm in a new movie
uh called quiet explosions it's on
amazon prime and
we took
athletes and soldiers and just everyday
common people who were struggling with
their moods
their behavior their emotions
and put them on a rehabilitation program
and it's so exciting i mean it's been my
life the last 30 years i mean why would
i do something where my colleagues hate
me
i don't like it when people don't like
me i mean i'm not i hate conflict and
now the sudden i'm i'm in a war
and
but you know
because you believe
um and it was always the stories it was
the stories of transformation
um
i have a
story i tell and somebody posted it on
um online and it got 40 million views
and i tell my hero's story it's like so
why do i do this well
i do it because i love it and it's
interesting it makes me a better doctor
but in 1995 my nine-year-old nephew
andrew attacked a little girl on the
baseball field for no reason and i'm
horrified because i love this child he's
also my godson and when i scanned him it
turned out he had a cyst the size of a
golf ball occupying the space of his
left temple
and when they drained it
his behavior completely
went back to normal
so
was he bad
no
he was sick
and if we don't understand that yeah
we just continue to hurt people shame
people label people
we can do better
how do what's the type of scan people
use to look for cysts or brain scan or
brain tumors or something what's that an
mri or ct you're great to look for
tumors
spectral give you an idea about it but
it's not the right study for it
okay okay so mri is for actual physical
masses but spec for activity
for activity you want to see the pattern
so i published a large study on 21 000
people
showing i could show the difference
between emotional trauma
and physical trauma and that's really
important because emotional trauma
actually leaves a signature pattern
in your brain so if you grew up in an
alcoholic home or unpredictable parents
or you were robbed raped in a fire
um
earthquake or
a hurricane
it actually takes your emotional brain
and heightens it
well
for a lot of people it stays that way
and so they're always looking
for something bad to happen
and i did a study for example with
police officers who were involved in
shootings and they couldn't go back to
work because they were so upset so i
scanned them and then we treated them
with a psychological treatment called
the emdr the specific psychological
treatment for emotional trauma
and after eight sessions they all went
back to work
and their emotional brains had calmed
down
okay this is very interesting
um
i'm dealing with so i'm trying i'm kind
of on a search to help this akathisia
and i've been on the search for a few
years and i have done
everything i could possibly find
hyperbaric nad
every supplement
that i thought maybe could work talk to
a whole bunch of people
emdr
i don't know like i don't know what else
but we've never done a brain activity
scan because i oh my god i don't know
why no one suggested that that's insane
here i am doing mris
yeah that probably won't help um
definitely let me send you my book
memory rescue because that's i would
think okay how can i get my dad's brain
to be in the most
healing
environment
and then a scan would totally be helpful
um
to see
you know is there any lasting damage
and
what can you do to repair it
yeah how much can you actually repair a
brain like how damaged does it have to
get before you're like you you see a
scan and you're like you know what
you're going to have some of these
forever and there's nothing you can do
like how much recovery can somebody with
brain damage get
yeah it depends on what they started
with and how bad the damage is i once
treated an 18 year old girl
um
who had a door fall on her head when she
was two and it killed her frontal lobes
she well isn't gonna get her that much
better but
95
of the people we see
they get better when they do the things
we ask them
to do
you know compliance is really important
uh
yeah
how important is belief
well i think belief is central
to
[Music]
they've actually studied this
that if you believe in the doctor and
the doctor believes in this method
everything
is better
um yeah
but if you really have pictures
and you have direction
um another thing i'd think of without
catheters they're any
um toxic load
you know things like heavy metals or any
infections
going on as well
and i have this mnemonic you'll
read about in the book called bright
minds you want to keep your brain
healthy or rescue it so with acasesia
we're going to rescue it if the brain's
headed for trouble we have to prevent or
treat the 11 major risk factors that
steal your mind and we know what they
are
and
you know part of it so it's not just a
scan it's a scan
and then we go through these 11 things
and go
okay which of whom do you have and which
can we attack
so bright minds is the mnemonic the t is
toxins when i think about anesthesia i
think of toxins oh yeah you know the b
is for blood flow and r is retirement
and aging and i is inflammation and g is
genetics ages head trauma and so on
we're just like going okay how do i put
the brain in a healing environment
can you tell me what mine stands for too
so the m
um
sorry
mental health issues so adv anxiety
depression the second eye is immunity
and infections
who knew and there's gonna be a whole
sub-specialty of psychiatry in 30 years
on an infectious disease psychiatry and
covet is going to lead the way
for that coveted lime uh the n is neuro
hormone disorders so if your hormones
are right your brain isn't right d is
diabetes
overweight or have high blood sugar uh
yes is sleep and so getting ready who's
right is essential
so do you diagnose sleep disorders as
well by looking at what areas the brains
aren't active or are too active can you
see that on brain scans you know what we
can see is if you're not a good sleeper
because overall blood flow will be lower
and if you have sleep apnea where you
snort loudly stop breathing at night um
it actually shows what almost looks like
an early alzheimer's pattern in the
brain with damage to your pro antelopes
wow this is
this is crazy
okay do you ever give out advice like
what are the top three worst things you
can do for your brain
well number one is not care about it
um
that's i think it doesn't matter yeah
what you're what you know and i live in
newport beach
where we have more plastic surgeons than
almost anywhere in the world and i'm
like we care more about our faces our
breasts our bellies and our butts than
we do our brain and that's just insane
um so it's been oblivious
uh that would be number one not caring
being oblivious um
having a sad
diet so the standard american
diet and
allowing your children to do brain
damage in sports it's just a dumb
to let a child hit a soccer ball with
their head
just do anything other than that yeah
okay when you give diet advice to people
who come in what what what are the
overarching themes
um real food um
colorful
well
so number one is high quality calories
calories matter when 72 of us are
overweight and 42 of us
are obese
you know let's not forget chemistry
calories matter but quality matters as
much or more um water because 80 of your
brain is water 70 of your body
is water
healthy protein at every meal because it
helps balance your blood sugar healthy
fat lots of it in your diet because 60
of the solid weight of your brain
is fat
colorful
low glycemic high fiber fruits and
vegetables
and get rid of the bad stuff
things that are artificial things that
are sprayed with pesticides
and learn to take care of your gut
because your gut
you know it's sort of a tie it's really
not the second brain it's part of your
first brain
uh so food really it just matters so
much
okay what kind of recovery have you seen
using hyperbaric oxygen you mentioned
that you know i published a study on it
in soldiers who were involved in blast
injuries and significant improvements to
blood flow
uh to the brain i've seen
a lot of great results from it
anybody has low blood flow in their skin
it's one of the things i'll
recommend for them
what about do people have high blood
flow
sometimes how people have ocd
uh
often they have too much activity
in their brain
sometimes we seizure disorders we'll see
a
focal area of increased activity
and so
do you not recommend that those people
do hyperbaric oxygen or is it still a
healthy thing to do well if your brain
is healthy and has good blood flow i
don't see hyperbaric oxygen making
things better
um
now it's approved for
a whole bunch of wound healing
indications
you know like you have a diabetic foot
ulcer i've also seen it help with wounds
in the brain
like head trauma or strokes
okay
interesting
do you know anything about saunas and
brain health
well if i flip my camera around i
actually have an infrared sauna in my
office here do you have a clear light
sauna what kind of sauna is that i do i
have a clear light sauna i'm so jealous
sauna's made such a difference to my
mental health when i was coming off of
ssris it was like diet was first but
i had this horrible impending doom
feeling
and getting in the sauna would eliminate
it for a number of hours
i had no idea why because it activates
heat shock proteins
and it tends to calm you down there's
actually study in jama's psychiatry
where just one sauna session had
antidepressant effects
and people who take the most saunas have
the lowest risk of alzheimer's disease
what
how could that be i know there's
heat shock proteins but do you think
there's more to it have you thought
about that at all well
you know if you want to get rid of the
toxins you can drink water you can stop
drinking alcohol you can eat more fiber
but one of the best ways is to sweat
with exercise or
with a sauna
get rid of the toxins in your body
okay well that makes sense maybe
lowering inflammation
okay this is fascinating
how much because my audience said this
is going to be a question asked how much
are these brain scans and everything you
do to treat these people
um it depends on what we do we have all
sorts of different packages you know i
think we we have our most popular
package is
um our six month package it's about
forty five hundred dollars two scans
history seen the doctor
a number of times uh that's almost
popular package
over a period of six months yeah that's
pretty good with the scans okay
interesting okay let me see that thank
you very much that answered a lot of
things i might have to
come over there and see what this looks
like um
how you use supplements in part of your
treatment
so
how do you
how do you increase something like
serotonin with supplements
so i have two supplements that i love
one called serotonin mode support that
has
uh 5-htp
and saturial which is a saffron extract
and then we have something that i take
every day called happy saffron saffron
zinc and curcumins all of them
independently have studies showing it
decreases depression
and improves mood and rather than steal
your sex drive or your ability to
function
i always hated that about the ssris you
know they come between people in a bad
way
that saffron has actually been shown to
enhance mood memory and sexual
functioning
i'm like well why wouldn't i do that
first um it doesn't cost as much
yeah that the you know first do no
harm which is why i got excited about
supplements about 30 years ago
i think people just don't believe it
right you've been taught one thing for
so long that you're like well no drugs
work supplements are for california and
hippies
yeah and who would benefit with that
message
it's the pharmaceutical industry so
they'll perpetuate it
yeah um but you know i mean the benefit
of supplements is
you never have to tell an insurance
company you're taking them as awful as
it sounds taking psychiatric medications
dark but true with your insurability to
get life insurance and long-term care
insurance
disability insurance
um
[Music]
they're less expensive they have
dramatically
fewer side effects but not no side
effects um
and
the downside is well they may be more
expensive for you because insurance
companies don't cover them
um
and your consultant for supplements is
usually the teenage clerk at the health
food store
so
you might not get really great
information
so on pubmed today they're 15 000
scientific references on spec
and
let's just take st john's war
their
studies
they're 29 randomized controlled trials
showing it's as effective as
antidepressants
with
you know like a quarter of the side
effects so let's just not say something
to play
to the media you know let's you know
talking truth
and
there's a lot of science people just
don't know it because that's not their
job so they believe when their doctor
says oh there's no science
yeah fair
if you're on something like an ssri too
you're told not to take st john's wart
so obviously there's something to that
or 5 htp for that matter
yeah um because you know you may end up
with too much serotonin
so you want to have a practitioner you
trust to give you guidance
okay
did i read is it possible that i read
something online about emfs inspect
scans
um you know it's possible i don't know
reference off the top of my head there
are a lot of people that are very
concerned about electromagnetic fields
and that's it are you on the brain
and
um 5g and all of that yeah yeah i'm
concerned
i'm not sure what we can do about it
except if you're going to be in a
vulnerable
state
uh protect yourself as much as you can
hmm
i was hoping i didn't have to be
concerned about emfs
i was like
that seems too far i don't want to worry
about that
okay
i think it just depends if you're doing
great
do
the simple things you know and brain
health basically it's these three things
bring them b gotta care avoid things
that hurt it know the less and do things
that help it when you're suffering you
have to really ramp that up
and that's where things like emfs
might come into play
okay that makes sense if you already
have some damage and you're super
sensitive when i had um ssri damage i
would say i was very sensitive to
fluorescent lights they were horrible
and now they don't bother me as much
i think well there's this funky thing
called erlan syndrome
irlan.com very common and people have
had concussions
um and people become light sensitive and
certain colors of the light spectrum can
actually give them headaches
can
give them depth perception problems or
reading problems and putting on colored
filtered lenses
makes a huge positive difference
for them so if that anybody in your
audience relates to that erwin
irl.com
uh they have some self tests and i've
had so many great
um
victories from helping people by sending
them for an hour on screen
and so they're wearing colored glasses
not just something like a red light a
blue a blue light filter
like that kind of for everyone i have a
hockey player now
who had a wicked concussion when you see
a guy hitting him and then his head
hitting the ice is awful and then he was
very light sensitive and putting on
the glasses his headaches went away
wow brains are insane
okay
um
that that's crazy do you also do okay
last question we're running out of time
when you bring people in do you do like
micronutrient testing and vitamin
testing to make sure they're not low in
vitamin d or something like do you do
kind of an overall
search or is it mostly that um
because if your vitamin d level is low
you're going to have a harder time
getting well
if your testosterone even as a woman if
that's low you're going to have a harder
time being happy
we'll check
your iron level for example
critical low
iron goes with
add goes with anxiety goes with insomnia
high iron goes with premature aging so
there's a whole list of labs we
generally order around our patients
wow
okay
that's really that's very cool
well
i guess my last case last last question
what is it like i've looked you up i
followed you for a while i know you deal
with a lot of celebrities what is it
like being a celebrity doctor
um
[Music]
it's just like being a doctor with
i mean all my patients are cool
um some of my celebrities
um
like i'm in justin bieber's docuseries
seasons
and
like many celebrities he'd show up he
wouldn't show up he'd do what i say
wouldn't do what i said
and then um
one day i came into my office
and he said my brain is an organ
like my heart is an organ
he said i think i get it
if you told me i had heart disease i'd
do everything you said he said i'm gonna
start doing everything you said
and he got so much better
so
at the beginning of the pandemic miley
cyrus called me up and she was freaking
out like everybody else
and as i helped her she goes will you
go on instagram with me tomorrow and
help my followers
and
the thing i love about that is it
expands the message
yeah and so
if you can get people like miley and
justin saying i suffer
it normalizes
other people
who suffer
um
so
um
so
it's been a better blessing
for me
okay well if people
weren't aware of who you are uh where
can they go to find you and follow you
uh
eamonnclinics.com so eamon liked the
last word in a prayer imagine growing up
with that last name
uh
amenclinics.com
or they can follow me on facebook at dr
danny layman or instagram at
doc underscore
amen
okay thank you very much for coming on
that was very interesting
well thank you so much for having me i
really enjoyed getting to talk to you
[Music]
you